i heard you've been watching anime
recently connor
which is which is a rare which is a rare
feat
i remember i used to do that i know the
anime man
what happened did you guys watch
castlevania yeah the new season
i have not season four now but we
haven't talked about castlevania yeah
it's so good
yeah it's so good i mean with how well i
mean i watched up to season three
yeah if there's one anime i have like
kind of caught up to it's castlevania
but like what did you get up to
castlevania i got up to season
three so i haven't finished season three
i'm about halfway through season three
yeah yeah i mean but i mean it's just
been for me it's been getting
better and better every season because
it's been going on and i just haven't
had time to binge it yet
so um i don't know man everything about
that anime especially the past season
just blew out the waterfall what's so
good about it
like i feel like everything that was
good in previous seasons was at its best
this season yeah really the story was
the best
the animation was just insane like some
of the fights even though in season
three the fights like the final fight
was so good even season one had some
great animations yeah
it just feels like they've stepped it up
like again like i think one of the
strongest points of castlevania has been
the voice acting
yeah it's voice acting english is
fantastic it's insane
the fact that they have like all the all
the accents
on point none of the accidents feel
silly yeah every single accent that the
characters have it feels genuine every
single british accent
is on point yeah and it's like holy [ __ ]
how do they do this
this never happens how do they get an
actual accent it's like they hired
british actors like i love the fact that
for example that jojo in the dub
like tried to do the accent yeah i wish
they'd got the native
people yeah yeah yeah yeah because like
in jojo part one it's uh johnny and bosh
doing in a
british accent which is yeah it is which
isn't bad but i know there's no
shortage of native english uh british
accents
in that can work in l.a yeah you know
like it it feels like the
voice actors they hide for castlevanias
were just outside of your usual they
were just
general actors that would act in like a
tv series or like a live-action movie
well yeah because they have like they
have such a good variation of
british accents like they have like the
whole spectrum and each
and they've chosen it like the character
has given the accent based very
specifically on like
where what it would be in the uk like
you're where you were born your wealth
your
socioeconomic background it sounds like
it's so stupid but it fits every single
character
and uh it's just insane because i mean i
i you we can't appreciate it i mean i
can we can't appreciate that in the
japanese one where you might get
regional accents on point
within their own show right sometimes
you get like the subtitles where they're
supposed to be a bit more like
oh sakura yeah yeah yeah yeah a bit
rough i can't really appreciate that
yeah
honestly i've been appreciating japanese
voice acting a lot more recently
yeah um yeah because i've actually i've
actually started to watch
anime without subtitles on right so i'm
like properly
forced wow you are like listen level 100
we right now
oh yeah exactly you're at the final
stage before you graduate
exactly exactly so like the final test
yeah so i'm like trying trying to pick
up more of my japanese and
you know part of the exercise i've been
putting myself through is like
everything i watch now
not subtitled like yeah my enjoyment has
definitely
of anime gone down but it's like this
helps it it helps
so much more it's it's a night and day
watching with subtitles without
subtitles when you don't understand
something that's being said
how do you do you go back and turn
subtitles on or just yeah so normally i
watch anime on crunchyroll or
netflix right so crunchy will also have
the opportunity to
select no subtitles so i can select no
subtitles if there's something that i
really really want to know what they
said i just rewind a bit turn on
subtitles like oh okay that's what he
said right
move on right same thing with netflix as
well yeah um i mean it's it
it turns anime to not just like a
passive watching thing and you're just
like
studying material yeah so it is study
material but if you're going to have
study material at least have study
materials
um it's just it's just a different kind
of watching in my eyes but um
since then i like i remember recently
i've been watching nagatoro
without subtitles and i had like my
first
emotional response to watching an anime
and without having subtitles on it was
just
felt it felt nice because i'm just like
oh i i get what's going on
i'm getting emotional these japanese
people is this this is your life is this
one yeah
that's exactly what i found it's like oh
i'm i'm feeling some stuff now
japanese people feel i'm not i'm not
reading the subtitles and getting
feelings i'm actually hearing it i'm not
listening to it
yeah i don't know how to quite describe
it because it was it was a new feeling
for me well gone i do the same thing
just with hentai
because they don't have subtitles most
of the time so i i just watched it fair
enough
i feel big brain when i kimochi i'm like
yeah
i got that
i remember going through my japanese
classes and it like i was like uh
so naka means inside and i was like
where have i heard the term
knuckles center yeah yeah like inside
well i've
heard oh that's the way i've heard that
before
it's that's a word you'll hear quite
often yeah that's been many different
contexts
yeah that's that's that's the word i've
i've learned from hentai that i can all
i can always go using daily life
it's like the the [ __ ] the drinking
with the [ __ ] coffee watching
subtitles
anime with no subtitles watching hentai
i can already see them but i mean yeah
sorry yeah the voice acting is [ __ ]
stellar man i i yeah dude it was like
castlevania
we would i would only be watching dubbed
out i mean like
do you think it's it played a massive
part too i i assume it's
a big part of it is because it was
dubbed first in english
rather than uh rather than dubbed from
japanese to english
is there a japanese doll for i'm pretty
sure there must be i've never seen it in
japanese
i don't know if i'll be able to when you
watch when you watch the dub it's so
goddamn good
it's actually a shame to watch it in any
other language yeah maybe this is how
japanese people feel with
yeah yeah yeah we'd have a choice but
when we have a choice why would you you
know
you know pick the one thing that is best
right yeah and uh this is definitely one
of those shows where i'm like it's it's
it's not even a competition yeah yeah
because like then obviously it was yeah
yeah because when i watched season one i
was like all right well the default is
in english
yeah because it's an english production
all right i'll watch episode one if this
is
you know voice acting is kind of subpar
then whatever i'll change it
yeah but literally first five minutes i
was like all right english newsletter
all right so this is this is fantastic
it's like an anime that is written with
kind of pretty
pretty [ __ ] good american i would say
it's american writers right so i feel
like it's
it's a lot easier for the actors to
because it's like very scripted yeah
because the dialogue is like very witty
and very smart
because you hear the dialogue and it
doesn't feel like anime dialogue it's
so [ __ ] funny it's good it's very
very witty and like facetious
it's just like it it's so rare to find
an anime dub where people actually swear
you know like i can count them on one
hand you know when once when someone
says [ __ ] or [ __ ] i'm like oh
oh this this stuff's going hard no we're
not in japan anymore
yeah so like hearing hearing it just
like said so naturally
you know like like any like talking to
any other brit or aussie you know it's
it's
it's it's something that's like just
ingrained into our speech
if you listen to trash taste you'd
[ __ ] know that um
but it's crazy because it doesn't feel
forced no no yeah because there's a lot
of times where they're like we're
to be a little uh explicit just just to
you know be like ooh edgy and everything
but like
in castlevania it's like yeah i can
imagine that yeah yeah that would
totally say that because like when you
hear it in an anime or like an anime
video game because i remember
the most recent example i can think of
is playing persona 5.
dubbed and hearing where you g ryuji say
[ __ ] i'm just like
eugene wash your mouth sir you want us a
child
excuse me when trevor belmont's like oh
for [ __ ] sake yeah that's nice